the lure of freedom
travel and simplicity in a snug
self-sustaining van
has given birth to a worldwide social
media phenomenon
which in part has been fueled by the
pandemic the hashtag van life generates
millions of pictures and videos
of nomads in the retrofitted vans parked
on beaches
opening up to stunning views or
underneath starry skies
for some it's freedom and others it's
necessity
madison mcnair and her husband rainer
spent about two years living out of
their van
in 2020 after 120 000 kilometers
the couple decided to share their skills
with others they opened a van conversion
shop
in a small town on the southeastern
shore of georgian bay
in ontario
we had just started construction when
the pandemic was declared and i
honestly thought it was like the end we
made the wrong investment we're going to
be in trouble
[Music]
but kovitt has only accelerated business
canadians are fleeing lockdowns and big
mortgages and rent for 80 square feet
mobile living spaces
to roam and work wherever and whenever
they want
madison says they can barely keep up
with the demand
it's been really incredible so we're
already booking into 2022
and 2023 now it seems laughable that i
ever thought there would be a decline
because of course if you're stuck at
home you're suddenly looking at your
backyard realizing we
live in an incredible region why not go
road trip
for some it is the allure of the
ultimate trip my name is drew
my name is max i'm zara margie
we're a family from vancouver we just
moved into a
60 square foot living space we're gonna
see if he can survive
and not kill each other the nine family
from bc
hit the road in 2019 for a two year
adventure
they decided they wanted their children
to learn about the world
firsthand when we caught up with them
they were parked at a dive shop in crete
greece
how did you end up your entire family
becoming van lifers
we just want to travel we want to find a
way that's
most economical for us and spend more
time with the family
we were trying to get away from the
rat race and just live
life live life to the fullest we wanted
a van or a vehicle
that we the four of us can live
comfortably so we actually
ended up building one our van name is
yolo just because we only live once
and that's sort of our motto
touring ancient ruins allowed the kids
who were being homeschooled to see
history
come to life their days were packed with
adventure
let's go back to march 2020 when the
pandemic hit
and the world shuts down what was going
through your mind
we weren't sure if it was how the
pandemic was going to affect
canada the borders morocco where we were
at the time
we even talked about should we come back
and finish this trip but
we just contemplated and decided you
know what
everyone in the world is living the same
thing
we just need to adapt but adapting in
some ways seemed easier for the family
the simplicity of van lifestyle the
self-containment and self-sufficiency
allowed them to stay safe while
traveling during covet
this is a very useful storage we have
for quick access
things that we would need every square
inch fits our lifestyle and we learn how
to live minimally
so the kids learn to bring
only what brings joy to them give me an
example
of how the pandemic has affected your
life as van lifers because
of different lockdown scenarios and
people are concerned about traveling
all the tourist spots are practically
empty so we
have these beautiful places almost to
ourselves and enjoy it without
the crowds and the lineups we've been
pretty lucky about that van dwelling
van lifeing vehicle residents is not a
new concept
there are versions peppered throughout
history one example is this land yacht
created for travel in the early 1900s
another is the popular volkswagen
microbus synonymous with hippie
counterculture of the 1960s and 70s
i think it was kind of one of the funny
things for us getting into van life and
me on instagram hashtag van life at
first
you feel like this pioneer creating this
new way
and then we met a lovely woman in the
desert of arizona and she concluded
so you're the same as i was when i was
in my youth we just had a crappy vw that
didn't work very well ultimately this is
the version of getting mobility getting
flexibility
going after whatever the gold rush is
that you're going after
it's quite natural and it feels really
natural
when you're in it
squamish bc an adventurer's playground
of majestic mountains
and rivers for renowned rock climber
thomasina pidgeon
this is home i started living in a van
in kind of like when i was 20 when i
moved away from home
it just feels super natural it feels
like the way that i'm supposed to live
it just feels right to me like
when i'm in a house i feel really
restricted i don't feel that comfortable
when i'm in a vehicle i just feel more
free that's the affordable
campground for more than 25 years
thomasina has been a vehicle resident
and celebrating the freedom it allows
her this is also another place that
we stay at some time she owns a business
in town
and lives in this 1998 toyota sienna
with her 14 year old daughter
for me it's a choice people that rent
houses choose to pay rent so they choose
to have a mortgage because that has the
lifestyle that they want and the
conveniences they want
i don't even want those conveniences for
me that's like an economic freedom too
i think people just don't need that much
stuff peter's clothes and
our book while the 46 year old prefers
this form of living
others choose it out of necessity the
last year of job losses the inability to
pay rent
and the red-hot housing market has
forced more people into vehicle living
even if thomasina wanted to she couldn't
afford the skyrocketing rent in squamish
there's people that are doing it because
they just have no choice
and then there's people like me i mean i
actually i don't really make that much
money i own my own business but
the amount of money that i make is below
poverty level i think in march i paid
myself six bucks an hour it's like i
couldn't even
pay rent if i wanted to but i don't want
to you know some food
uh yeah just some teas some
jurisdictions have rules prohibiting it
so it's unclear just how many people
live in their vehicles across canada
and as the affordable housing crisis
worsens tensions between cities and van
dwellers seem to be growing
you see them throughout parts of metro
vancouver people living not
in homeless camps but in rvs after
letting the issue
slide for much of the pandemic the city
of vancouver is now cracking down
some municipalities are cracking down on
rvs trailers and vans illegally parked
on streets
squamish is no exception passing by-law
changes that would prevent people
sleeping in their vehicle overnight
in certain public spaces thomasina
co-directs the advocacy group
fighting the bylaw it penalizes people
for doing something which is a basic
human right which is to sleep
it's just a really exclusive bylaw that
to me is driven by stigma karen elliott
is the mayor of squamish she says the
amendments are to manage the tourist
population
and not aimed at long-term vehicle
residents it is not targeting
people that call squamish home full time
it really is about managing the influx
of thousands
of vehicles each summer and thousands of
people that are looking for a place to
stay
the mayor hopes the bylaws encourage
visitors to sleep at camp
sites this is also an option for vehicle
residents
we understand that that vehicle sleeping
might have to be a reality for some
folks but for this summer
we needed a solution for the visitor
management
and that for us is the priority as for
thomasina she plans to live in her van
indefinitely and won't change because of
the bylaw why should i have to hide why
do people always have to hide and
pretend that they don't exist because
people don't agree with a certain type
of lifestyle like to me that's just
wrong like i wish that people would just
be more open-minded and not be so
judgmental to a different way of living
that it's actually
pretty minimal and simple and to me it's
a beautiful lifestyle
back at madison and raynor's shop
there's no slowing
down and they know the van life trend
will continue
out of choice or necessity rent's
expensive
jobs are in stable how do i sign a
12-month lease
if my job won't give me a 12-month
stability how do i pick a place to live
these vehicles are far more about
freedom
self-control autonomy there's this
balancing act that i hope we find
there's ways we can adjust and see the
benefits for this
the employment opportunities are
important and giving
canadians the opportunity to find where
they belong
is important